[Music]
all right hello hello everyone and
welcome back
to the end game class today i'm going to
be walking you through
some end games from the legends of chess
tournament
that is going on right now over on chess
24
uh some really exciting games really
exciting players
in the event as i was saying in the road
to 2000 class
today was the final day of the
preliminary stage of the events
and the top four are now moving on to
knockout finals it's going to be
really exciting to watch i hope you guys
get a chance to watch the action live
i've been following it pretty closely
and and having a great time
with the event uh and like i said in the
endgame class today we're going to go
over some end games from it some of you
might recognize this position from the
road
2000 class that just that we just
wrapped up here
uh and i said in that class that i would
go over this end game in a little bit
more
detail that yan did end up winning
because i think it was a really
interesting one
and pretty instructive as to some
defensive ideas
and some attacking ideas to try to break
down these defensive structures
that white was was creating so let's
jump into it here
uh we have of course gal fan
with the white pieces playing this
position uh a pawn down
when really it it does feel like two
pawns right white's extra pawn is this
f-pawn which isn't really going anywhere
and black has these two pawns that are
connected
and passed uh what's the good news
for white and the good news for white is
that there are bishops of
opposite colors and this affords white
some really interesting
defensive ideas that otherwise wouldn't
really be
successful uh the main
defensive idea that we're going to see
gelfand employ here
is the idea of a dark square blockade
he's gonna try and stop these pawns on
light squares
before they ever get a chance to cross
over another dark square
towards uh queening sort of
if black can manage to get this pawn to
c2 black is more often than not
just going to directly be be winning the
game but
if white can keep this stronghold on c3
then white might be able to stop these
pawns forever
and draw the game of course i say
that this is an option afforded to white
because the bishops are of opposite
colors
of course if the bishops were on the
same color like this bishop on e7 for
this bishop would be on e7 for example
you can imagine black could very easily
break down this
blockade by just transferring this
bishop to the same diagonal
when they would sort of be on level
footing
right so the idea of this dark square
blockade is going to be what gelfand
tries to do tries to use here to draw
this game
then we're going to see how jan tries to
break this blockade and goes on
to win the game
it's been five minutes yeah i was told
that my mic was doing funny things so i
unplugged it plugged it back in tried to
make sure it sounds good also got some
water
in the interim hopefully you guys are
okay with this
isn't this a draw objectively probably
the time
was the problem honestly
i don't know um it's one of those
positions
where objectively it might be a draw
but as you play and play and play and
play play it's very easy to sort of let
something slip so let's let's see what
happened
uh dang tim has banned me from drinking
water
it's gonna be tough let's see if i can
abide by that law
uh rook c8 is how this end game started
of course
uh jan just defending this guy from the
threat of capture note that he didn't
really want to play d5
because it just blocks in this bishop
for absolutely no reason
much better to have this pawn on d6 for
as long as possible hampering this
bishop a little bit
and allowing his bishop some some
freedom here
so rook c8 and king f2 is natural
getting the king in the game
uh black brings this bishop out to the
e4 square
and now white plays the move g4 sort of
making his extra pawn on the king's side
be felt a little bit king f7 is very
natural i see king e3
bishop d3 and king d2 kimi 6
and so far so good both sides just
advancing the kings
and note that black has immediately
placed his bishop on what might be the
best square
on d3 the reason this is probably the
best square
is it slows down white's advances
on the king's side it defends the c pawn
and i can sort of
interfere with uh some
connections some communication between
the white pieces right it's tough to
talk to this bishop
on d4 with this bishop on d3 and pawn on
c4 sort of standing in the way uh in the
game
we saw rookie one check and this king
comes up to d5
and this bishop now does leave and goes
all the way to f6
and so far white hasn't done anything
wrong
in fact he he's done very very well for
himself
so far the pieces he wants to use to
blockade
are sort of this king in this bishop
which it which he is successfully doing
by guarding the c3 square twice right
uh now if black wants to
make progress he's sort of going to have
to make sure
that he drives one of these pieces away
or he finds targets elsewhere on the
board
uh now bishop f6 might have actually
been
slightly slightly inaccurate because of
black's next move that we see in the
game
maybe g7 was slightly better square
from f6 the move rook f8 is
playable and now unfortunately uh g5 has
sort of been provoked
and this extra f pawn is now sort of
meaningless and it does
really now officially just feel like two
extra pawns
for black that being said it's not the
the biggest change to the position
honestly
you can imagine something like this
happening instead and this pawn staying
on g4 for a little bit
the only difference is that in some
cases white would be able to sort of
make a counter threat with the move f5
uh but bishop f6 played in the game
and now after rook f8 g5 rook b8
is jan's choice and i don't think this
game is beyond saving
uh just yet i really don't think it is
beyond saving
um okay we see rook b eights the king
comes out to c3
and now a5 finance sort of just taking
over some more of the dark squares
advancing more pawns up the board
uh h4 was gal fans choice and this isn't
bad move it doesn't really change the
position
white's idea for now is to sit on this
blockade until he is forced off of it
and this is sort of the drawing
technique
that gail font gelfand is and should be
using here
uh rook b7 comes on the board we see
rook e7
of course any pure bishop end game is
going to be
an easier draw than with rooks on the
board we just know this about opposite
colored bishops
so this rook comes to b1 and now all of
a sudden
the the black rook is active and
this sort of development in the game
kind of makes me think
that perhaps it was in white's best
interest
to not actually touch this rook on e1
it's one of those positions where maybe
given infinite time
black might find some way to pose a
problem
for white but i don't see where that
problem
is is coming from is is coming from just
yet
for example what if white just passes
with bishop h8 bishop f5 maybe
bishop f6 and it's like how do you
actually make any progress
in this position i'm not so sure this
rook
could try and do things like this but it
does
feel like uh it's coming through a
little bit
slowly uh that being said rookie seventh
was the active choice
for gelfand
but i think practically this this was a
mistake
objectively rookie 7 isn't a bad move
but in practical game
practical games i think it makes sense
in positions like these
to force your opponent to show you an
idea before
you start going for for active play like
rookie seven
right right now white has this optimal
setup of this dark square blockade
and uh
jan's last move of rook b7 it is very
much not saying
that he's he's coming up with an active
idea just yet
so i would have liked to see golfing
sort of wait a little bit longer
wait for for nepo to come up with some
way to challenge the structure
and then kind of continue from there
that being said
rookie 7 rook b1 and now rook
a7 is uh gel fans idea
he is anticipating that black is looking
to challenge this a2 pawn
and instead is going after a5 before he
really gets the chance
now though we do see that yon gets to
break this blockade
using this rook the king has to step
away
and after rook c2 check the king steps
to a3
and the blockade is broken everybody
celebrates
it's an easy win for black now
uh and of course none of none of that is
true
uh the game is is definitely
far from over at this point
uh i'd like you guys at home to think
for a second
and try to come up with the most
testing to try right now for
black the the most forcing move we'll
say
so yeah a4a3 rook b2 maybe was another
active idea for black the point is
i just wanted white to sort of wait on
the position until uh
until black did show one of these ideas
chess king says rook f2 manny says no c3
now
king e4 chess king also mentioning
rook h2
ragnarok does say c3 tim chess
is king e4 so king e4 is actually the
move played in the game
and this is sort of the the slower move
uh this
is uh black trying to come take these
pawns on the king's side kind of round
them up
but in fact getting rid of these pawns
on the king's side doesn't actually
change the evaluation of the position
too much
uh the things on the king side are still
kind of maintaining
uh their current status being sort of
totally locked
and in the meantime white can can start
taking the a pawn as well
in exchange uh
the most testing move i believe is the
move rook c1
and why is this the most testing move
well it's because black wants to play c3
but tactically c3 just doesn't work in
the immediate position
due to king b3 when this pawn has no way
to save itself
rook c1 however is suddenly making the
threats
of playing the move c3
and i do think it's sort of
uh forcing white's hand a little bit
uh if white wants to go for a k5 check
king e4
and something like her k6 now all of a
sudden things do get rather complicated
in in lines such as these and
honestly i'm not sure what the
evaluation of this position is
but it's definitely progress for
black i would say even if white does end
up drawing
thanks to these extra pawns that he took
that being said there are ways to sort
of maintain the blockade here
uh after the move rook c1 actually i was
thinking white had to play the move
bishop b2
to main plane maintain the blockade when
you can
start coming back as well but now i'm
realizing that the move king b2 might
also just be
be possible when we're just sort of
repeating
that's uh rather funny
oh well so yeah not repeating moves
plays king e4 instead
but this idea of rook c1 and c3 i i did
want to highlight
even if actually it doesn't make the
most sense in that immediate position
so king e4 was black's trying to make
progress uh we have vert takes a5
and now d5 to cut this rook off from its
connection
to the center uh the root comes back to
a7 we have king takes f4
and white does collect this h pawn as
well in the meantime
uh king g4 was eons try and this isn't
my favorite move
i think if black wins this game it's
because he gets these center pawns
rolling
so it might make sense to have this king
closer to the center
but king g4 nonetheless rook a7
bishop e4 uh is just
sort of another waiting move by yon king
b4
rook c1 brook c7 king takes h4 now
and after a4 the end is is sort of
in sight here for uh
for galvan he's he's defended well so
far he's maintained this blockade
ensured that these pawns do not advance
up the board
but after jan's next or jan's next move
yeah
uh he makes a fatal mistake here
so rook be one check there is
actually only one move that draws in
this position
every other move is unfortunately just
losing so see if you guys at home can
find the draw after the move rook b1
check
sedan says king c3
everybody says king c3
crush says king a3
king a3 because king c3 is too obvious
says great wolf
so yeah the problem with king c3 is that
black gives you a check
and goes rogue a3 and now
you wouldn't really want to play the
move rook a7
because after rook d3 check
the king has to move and now d4
and this is sort of the the breaking up
of the blockade that you have to look
out for
um so instead you have to sort of
pass your time save c6 rick takes a4
c7 back to a3 or c6
and now this king's gonna come over and
uh eventually i think that the two pawns
should just win here if they are
completely uncontested
as they are in this case white sort of
needed that a pawn
in the game to make the draw
to sort of solidify his position to be
100 drawn
uh the play might continue uh let's say
black
or white just keeps passing king f3
rook a2 check and
oh sorry well i i've blundered here
sorry
so not rook c6 but rook c8 but uh
i'll say bishop f5 just for example
and how do we make progress here sorry i
know this end game should be winning
but how do we actually make progress
let's say rook d3 check
king c1 and king
e2 now we are advancing let's say
yeah i'll come to e3 instead why not
black white passes and
now after rook b3 white passes
well that's actually check me you just
got checkmated and
if you don't do this then uh
then black is invading anyways so sort
of with these pawns
and the freedom of movement of the black
king uh black
is able to sort of break break this
blockade
uh sorry that was a little bit rough
around the edges there i knew the sun
game was winning it just took me some
time
so in fact the only drawing move is the
move suggested
king a3 getting rid of this idea
of coming to a3 with the rook from black
and now white should be able to draw
this position
notably by coming to a3 and a2
we don't actually give up this blockade
we are still preventing c3
this check doesn't really do anything
and if black starts trying to run the
king over
we can start pushing our pawn a bit
and now we get to blockade as well as
defender pawn at the same time
and black is going to have a much more
difficult time getting these pawns
through
while he's having to babysit this pawn
on a5
so king a3 was the last critical move
that needed to be played
king c5 was gelfan's choice instead
and now of course white or sorry black
to move
and win the game how does black
win in this case
i played the most reporters like six
years old yeah unfortunately white
really can't do anything there you just
have to keep this blockade otherwise
otherwise uh black will just push the
pawns so
white kind of had no options other than
passing
well hold on you can't play c3 yet can't
play c3 yet bishop takes c3
so yeah tim has the right idea here you
go rook b3
and now c3 is in fact sort of
unstoppable
uh if you come to d4 trying to
re-establish the blockade
rook d3 check pushes you away and
i don't know if you play c3 immediately
but c3 is is sort of coming
maybe you don't play it immediately
because king b4 is strong
but uh i think this is sort of the same
as the game
where white just plays king d6 to sort
of keep this blockade
and now you have the same issue where
rook a3 picks up the pawn
as well uh king e5 king g4
and now we see that this is an even
better version
for black where the white king was not
able to get back in front of the pawns
and after c2 uh gal fanned through in
the town i
i skipped through those last moves
pretty quickly so let's go through those
once again
king d6 black picks up his pawn
and then uh brings the rook behind
back in front and just brings the king
in and pushes
critical moment was here when black was
able to push
c3 uh sort of uncontested with
the king on d1 ready to escort this pawn
all the way home
and so jan does win this end game
uh and yeah i thought this was a really
fun end game
uh to show you guys this
idea of blockading on the dark squares
is a really instructive way to play for
the draw
in these cases and then yawn always
being tricky managing to pick up white's
remaining counter
remaining pawns that were offering him
some semblance of counter play
is how this game ended up going his way
it's a good game for the endgame class
with moves like k3 yeah i
really did enjoy it as well uh okay
up next why don't we head on over
to everybody's favorite player in the
legends of chess tournament
piece fiddler of course not a niche
geary oh and i've restarted the game
of course we don't care about this this
is opening business and
middle game business and
all we care about is somewhere along the
way
peter swiddler has lost a pawn
and we have yet another bishops of
opposite colored colors and the game
where
uh svidler in this case is down the pawn
and we're gonna look at the game
from his side because i thought he came
up with some really great defensive
resources here
to keep the game going and eventually he
does go on
to draw this game although we'll see
there was a lot of back and forth and
maybe some missed wins
but it was a rather fun one
so what do you guys think is going on
here
with the black pieces what are uh
black's sort of main
priorities in this case we'll solve let
me play two more moves
instead i played the whole game but let
me play two more moves so we have
uh takes on e4 and h3
so black regains the spawn on e4 of
course and now eight
h3
okay we can back up one more step y rook
a7
well it was a pawn
i don't understand i don't think this
this offers much for uh
for white taking this for a penny so
rick takes a seven instead blacker
against the pawn and h3 so
what are the priorities
it's gearing us twins are a given don't
be too harsh on the guy he
he he did win uh one game against peter
today
um what are black's main priorities in
in this position here what should black
be hoping to do
what kind of setup are you going for and
how are you achieving it
chess king thinks it's a draw if all
pieces are traded except one pair of
rooks
well chess king you would be settling
centuries of debate then if you know
that those end games are drawn literal
centuries of debate have gone into
these end games with the one pawn on the
queen side and three versus three on the
king's side
and the pure reckon games sometimes
they're drawn sometimes they're not
so there are some ideas
some people are saying the rook should
go behind the past pawn
bishop blockade on a4 so yarrow is going
for a similar type of blockade to what
we saw in the previous game
trade the rooks the light squared bishop
can't help promote the a pawn
so yeah you guys have some some good
ideas here some good ideas
there are some useful
tips to know going into these end games
and you can sort of arrive at these tips
logically
the first thing you want to ask yourself
is
do trades favor me or hurt me and in
most cases with opposite colored bishops
as the defending side trades are really
always going to help you here
someone pointed out very astutely that
this bishop
is kind of a huge problem for black it's
creating all these types of mating nets
mating threats
around the black king and in tandem with
a rook
it could very well lead to checkmate
or worse don't ask me what worse is
but believe me it could get worse than
checkmate sometimes
so in general trades are going to be
favorable for
black what does that mean
well that means that it's actually
pretty easy to blockade this pawn
on a3 that's one way you can kind of use
this
to your advantage so how can we blockade
the pawn on a3 well we actually don't
even need the bishop's help to do it
we can just sort of shove this rook here
and then rather
than keep this bishop on this diagonal
regarding a4
we we can even remove it from the
diagonal right because
the reasoning is even if
uh even if this rook somehow gets
challenged by an opposing rook we don't
really care
because if the root gets challenged
we'll trade it off and trades are
favorable for us
we're making progress towards the draw
so that's something useful
to keep in mind here is that trades are
going to be useful
for black rook trades favor favor black
of course
black isn't as interested in trading off
the bishops
in some cases but in general a rook
trade almost always going to be
advantageous for black
something else to notice is that
is there some way we can solve the
problems that this bishop is is giving
us
right and so like rook h4 has been
mentioned
but let's say
you repeat for a turn this bishop can
come to f6
and on this diagonal you are not going
to be able
to permanently chase it away it's always
going to find a home
somewhere on this diagonal so
as black you should be thinking uh
priority number one is to make sure i
you know this pawn
doesn't advance we keep a4 under our
control
you can do so by blockading the square
and then
the second thing you really need to
worry about is ensuring your king's
safety
so is there some way that we can come up
with
to make sure we we aren't getting
checkmated
by this bishop in most cases
so some way to sort of permanently solve
the issues
that the bishop is is giving us these
mating threats
so donkey puncture says it'd be nice if
you could get
f6 and g5 not sound right now
but stop at that so he's on the right
track he's on the right track rather
than
f6 and g5 though you
quite often don't want to move this pawn
while your king is still in the back
rank
obviously in this case there's stuff
like check but you never really want to
do this because it can be difficult to
sort of excavate this king from the back
rank it's not impossible in these cases
because once again black can use the
fact that trades are advantageous
to his advantage my playing moves like
this to get out this way
but uh even better i think would be h6
and g5
so black all of a sudden from the
starting position where you might
just think black has nothing better to
do than shuffle the pieces
all of a sudden we're sort of coming up
with constructive ways to improv
to improve black's position and that is
sort of the the right way to go about
these these defensive uh positions you
want to try to find some way
to improve your position to the maximum
to
uh sort of deal with these threats and
problems that your opponent
is giving you in the game smither did
not actually start with rook h4 he could
have but instead he just played rook a4
directly
we have rook c7 and bishop d5 and this
was actually all played in the game
uh this example line that i showed that
is rook d1 now
challenges this bishop and so bishop e6
is preventing
white from doing any nasty doubling up
ideas
and invading on the back rank uh
rook d3 now uh white finally has to deal
with the threat to the pawn
and now svidler does in fact play the
move rook h4
we see bishop g5 and the rook comes back
to a4
uh now after bishop e7 see if you can
come up
with with black's next move
to this point black's play has been
pretty natural so far
you blockade the pawn you play some
forced moves when your bishop's attacked
put the bishop on a nice square stop
away from doubling up
and now yeah so sadat has the idea it's
what we were talking about before
it's finally time to play this move g6
go h6 g5
and all of a sudden our king can get
back into play
and this is just sort of fantastic now
for
black i say fantastic of course black is
still under a lot of pressure
and it's going to be tough to hold this
end game but this is progress
for black we don't often talk about
progress for the defending site
but black is getting closer and closer
to a secure draw
now one interesting idea that gary could
have tried is
a move like h4 to try and pin down
these pawns for a little bit but in the
long run
g5 is going to be difficult to stop
i believe for example brick e to a8
and already i think g5 is sort of
unstoppable
if uh black chooses to to play for it
for example kf2 and yeah already you can
play g5
the point being if you take this guy i
get to take this guy
uh so h4 might have been interesting but
geary understandably doesn't go for this
because
after g5 then it might be easier for
black to get pawns off the board
so we see bishop out to b4 instead
trying to isolate this rook over here on
a4
black wastes no time peter plays the
move g5 directly
and now after king h2 he marches his
king up the board
and sorry i skipped over gary's next
move here which is
f4 uh and why does geary play a move
like f4
which sort of looks like it's uh
initiating
just more trades of pawns and not making
uh definite progress
well it's because peter's fed uh peter's
fiddler's setup here
is is just going to be strong enough to
sort of withhold anything
that white can throw at it
it's becoming quite difficult in fact to
come up with constructive ideas
for white that don't involve just
trading this rook
on a4 so maybe you know white
could try something like rick's rick c5
rick a5
but black's gonna be happy to capture
this guy
and sort of just you know renew his
defensive stance here
so with black's
uh secure defensive setup now having
solved the problems around his king
that the dark squared bishop was giving
him gary did feel the need
to go for
go for something more direct with the
move f4
so yeah i guess i should ask do you
think g takes f4
is is a good idea here for black or or
not
should g takes f4 be played
bryce says no sedan says good idea
minnie says no that's not really helping
no no no no no
i don't think it's a bad move i think
it's it's a fine move but practically i
don't think it makes sense
right black's goal here is to limit the
number of things he has to worry about
and uh taking an f4
actually only really increases the
number of things he has to worry about
maybe it also increases the things that
white has to worry about
but that's not really spidler's aim here
he's not trying to give
white you know some fear of of this f4
pawn
but now he's kind of created an extra
weakness here
on h6 without this pawn to help
guard something so it does make more
sense in this case just to play king g6
and you would be much more happy with
this structure than the structure
that we uh we just looked at so king g6
instead
uh rook c5 was a nishikiri's try
to uh challenge this g5 pawn
uh and this is sort of how he's he's
playing for a win here
he's just trying to get at g5
and win the game in this manner
rook c8 is the great defensive move by
svidler
once again these rook trades can only
really favor
black so he's very happy to offer them
on
any occasion and now if geary wanted to
sort of keep the pressure up he could
have tried to move rookie five
uh but at this point there are a few
things
that uh black could play number one
black could still go for this change in
structure i still don't like this though
maybe better is just highlighting the
fact that this rook is running out of
squares
on this uh rank we would love to play
the move
f6 to kick it away so rook c6 would make
a lot of sense
then if rook g3 making a threat we
always have f6 here
and this rook is out of squares on this
this rank to continue attacking
although maybe this would be a bit of a
misstep because f5 might be strong
but f6 is shoring up our defenses
well enough probably this would have
afforded
geary the most winning chances in this
case
but you know even a move like rook c4
here and it's
getting rather difficult to keep track
of everything
for white uh in the game
he thought he spotted a tactic
so white to move and think he won
uh i'm waiting to move and
and think white wins i i don't know how
to phrase that grammatically it's it's
tough
white to move and and not win but white
to move and
uh play you know a quote-unquote tactic
of course the tactic
is f5 check when geary
you know maybe thought that swiddler had
blundered
uh bishop takes f5 is natural but now
after rook d6 check
every move loses for black king g7 loses
a bishop
bishop e6 loses a rook nothing to be
done
but the move f6 is unfortunately legal
and quite good here and there's nothing
really doing
for whites in the case of bishop c3
because uh black is able to defend this
pawn numerous ways
or even just capture on a3 when
nothing doing here for white
uh so after f5 we did see this happen in
the game
g4 was played but rook takes c5 hits
uh defends this bishop as well so
there's no inner mesos
then the game was quickly agreed to a
draw after rook d4
and so i wanted to show this end game
because it really shows some
fantastic defensive technique by svidler
and shows you this sort of logical
process that you can follow
to find moves in these kinds of end
games uh you sort of just
identify your problems as the weaker
side and then go step by step
trying to solve them one at a time using
things to your advantage
whenever you can in this case the main
thing being
that trades were advantageous for black
incorrect thinking you have a win is my
specialty
so yeah you guys were all making fun of
geary for for you know being the draw
guy
and like missing wins all the time in
this case he
he tried to win he thought he saw the
win he thought he had it he jumped at it
but still you know unavoidable
uh ending up with the drawn result
okay and i think at the beginning of the
sun game i said gary might have missed
some wins
he actually didn't i was thinking of a
different end game i don't know which
one i was thinking of but this one
was just well played start to finish by
black and no way to win
okay let's move on to a third
end game
um and oops this is not the end game
i was looking for
what do we have here no this is the
first end game oh my goodness here it is
all right
this is the game um this one i wanted to
show
first and foremost because it was rather
funny to start with
i was mixing up my nepo girlfriend games
uh rather funny to start with by jan he
plays
a3 and so we're gonna look from the
black side a3
which is already kind of a funny move it
makes some sense to go for b4
in some positions but pretty funny and
then here
after bishop c4 he just plays the move
h4 which is bordering on on ridiculous
here
uh anyways thankfully this is the
endgame class so we don't
have to spend too much time talking
about those things
instead we get to jump to the end game
and this was a very nicely played middle
game by boris i should say
a fun little exchange sacrifice white
sacrifices the exchange back and rook d1
queen f3 queen d4
and we are arriving at the end game
black
has to play queen h1 queen h6 to deal
with
the checkmating threat and now we have
the move d6
and so this is the end game i want to
talk about a really fun game
in the opening middle game but also
really interesting
end games so let's take a look at it
here
first and foremost what's going on well
black is
up not just one but actually two pawns
in this case
although of course you know the f pawns
are doubled
and white has this very very active very
scary looking d-pawn that black is gonna
have to contend with
so what is to be done
in this position in particular what's
going on here of course i think
everybody agrees
we'd rather have black as this white
pawn isn't queening immediately
and black is the one with the safe king
and the extra pawn
but what can black do to try and win the
game
wu tang says queen g7 and force the
queen trade
bryce says the a3 sicilian is deadly
don't underestimate it
combined with h4 i think it's a bit less
deadly
you can't play a3 and then play h4
you're sort of allowed
you're allowed to play one of these
tempo wasting moves uh per game
you can't do both of them
so i'm seeing some really good ideas a
lot of people want to start with
f3 check a lot of people are saying
queen g7
is a good idea
g5 g4 and f3 push the pawns
so okay all right priority number one is
making sure this guy doesn't queen
let's let's all get on the same page
here
long term probably this is not the way
excuse me this is not the way that black
tries to queen upon
black already has his past pawn in the
age pawn and so this is the guy
that black would want to push in the
long run to get a queen
so there are sort of two ideas here that
that black can try you know you can just
blockade this pawn immediately you can
throw on an f3 check and blockade this
pawn
or you can play this move queen g7 and
offer
this uh offer this queen trade
and the question is what's happening
after the move king d3 that's the
question
what happens after the move king d3
uh are we in time to trade the queens
or is white actually going to be the one
that benefits
from this queen trade more
because it's very easy to look at this
and say well goodness gracious
i'm catching this pawn but
that may not be the case after the move
king d3
so what do you guys think is this a good
idea for black
to uh to go queen g7 and go for this
so yeah rook d8 here so you can start to
kind of
switch ideas but now king c4
and all of a sudden the the white king
which was sort of
weak back in its own camp is starting to
look like a very fighting piece
right starting to look like a fighting
piece definitely now
we're not actually interested in this
queen trade when
you might start preferring white you
very much might start preferring white
if uh things things start going wrong
here
uh even rookie for check for example and
stuff like rp7
stuff like collecting this pawn this
stuff is coming as well
and black in fact might be losing these
positions
and so for this reason i actually don't
like the move queen g7 too much
i don't think after king d3 going for
the clean trade
is really a good idea uh
really in this position you should only
trade the queens if it means that you
get to the d-pawn
first if white's getting to the d-pawn
first with his king
then you don't want these queens off the
board
so in fact i i don't like the move queen
g7
too much in this case uh simply because
the move king d3
i think is is rather strong and i mean
the play might continue with something
like
g5 here when it's going to get rather
complicated
but i do think this is more double edged
than uh
but then then white deserves with this
pawn surviving and coming up the board
so i actually like what boris did in the
game which is play the move rook d8
uh he didn't throw in the move f3 check
and in fact maybe he
should have the only reason that uh
you would want to throw this move in is
because
uh after for example this line move king
e2
actually turns out to be a pretty nice
idea for white
the point being this king is just a
little bit closer and
the king on f3 is surprisingly safe and
also does a good job of hampering the
black pawns
however this is kind of a
counter-intuitive idea running into your
opponent's pawn majority with your king
so it's understandable why that was
missed uh to prevent it
black could have just played f3 here
first and then the king does kind of
have to run
in the other direction in the game
though we just saw rook d8
and queen f6 queen f8 uh all played
on the board um
and then white brought this king to c2
anyways which does seem
much more natural than coming to this
strange looking f3 square
even if you know the computer is saying
it's a bit better
uh yeah so throat punch coming in with
the quote chess openings
teach you chess openings and games teach
you chess so yeah
they do teach you a lot about how the
pieces work together
and how uh how the game of chess
actually works
so i tend to agree uh
so now i want to pause again we
are at uh sort of another crossword
crossroads for black uh black has sort
of
stemmed the bleeding here as for the
moment prevented this pawn from coming
too much forward
he continues with the move queen e8 to
prevent the move
uh d7 we see king b1
d7 king a1 and now once again
i actually do want to pause and say how
do you make
progress here with with black how do you
make progress
sorry i'm actually going to play two
more moves queen e6 is natural offering
a trade of queens queen takes f4 and now
i will ask you how
how you actually intend to make progress
in
this position
so billy club says harry harry the h
pawn
chess can kind of like swipe here
probably white is not to be preferred
in this position if anybody can try to
win here it's black
the reason being uh you can't ever
really afford to leave this pawn
uh if you do to try to advance it black
is gonna be happy to to snatch the guy
king to the red side
i've never heard of the red side of the
chessboard right he says
you had me interested i was interested
in the red side of the board i was like
i want to be on the red side of the
board that sounds like fun
so ragnarok's h5 nathan's
f5 and so yeah i mean you guys are
are on the right track here f f5
probably shouldn't be played
um in general i talk about this a lot
in many middle game lectures you don't
want to really be moving this f
pawn in many middle games because in the
resulting
end games the f pawn result uh provides
a lot of shelter
for the king along the seventh rank and
that's the case here
you kind of want this pawn back on f7 to
shelter the king from anything happening
on uh on this rank uh
h5 though is a very natural way to start
so we do see king g7 2 and h5 but now
you arrive at this problem where it's
like how far do you want to go with this
guy
you know if if you kind of push him
nonchalantly
uh you might run into some problems
right let's say queen c3 check
king h7 queen d4 this all happens in the
game
uh for the moment you can't push h4
queen g4 uh tries to make it a reality
f4 played in the game
and now are you guys ready actually to
start pushing harry
are you ready to push this guy up the
board yes yes or no
h4 here
are you ready to push this guy
dice says no chess king says push push
tim says no king is out of position no
manny says no because the clock's
disappeared so we realized i
it wasn't played in the game
so okay all right all right it seems
like everybody wants to put the king
on g8 before pushing the h pawn because
they're worried
that the pun might get taken with checks
so okay we'll play queen e6
as in the game a4 king g8
rook d3 all right are you guys happy can
we push the h pawn now
yes or no
aaron says yes ragnarok says push
yes it's time
all right all right let's try it let's
push it h4
h4
everybody agreed oh and suddenly now
everybody says no
and yeah bryce has the reason why it's
not actually going to be
be working here white has a really
incredible defensive resource
in the position to uh
sort of lock down the black pieces and
it's it's one that's
actually pretty crazy here so so white
to move
and find the the draw
white to move and find the draw pretty
much
so yeah it is in fact the move f5
uh if g takes f5 you're sort of asking
to get checkmated and losing this pawn
as well
so you might lose the game and if queen
takes f5
queen takes h4 of course is impossible
due to queen d3
but white can first play this tricky
move rook
e3 threatening a checkmate of his own
and after something like her d8s now
this pawn
does fall off the board once again
you're not so happy taking this guy
because of checkmate so
it's these really tricky defensive ideas
that yan
is using to sort of keep gelfand at
bay here and so that's why we saw check
check
and then king h7 so now gailfand once
again
is stepping out of the idea of rookie
eights but now
there's still a problem that we ran into
the first time which i don't know if i
ever actually mentioned
um this problem of
if you push h4 now your king is sort of
stuck on on this h file and rook h1
is going to be good enough here uh
just for example queen g3 i think
already you can play f5
maybe not because of g5 actually but you
could play something like queen e4
and now you were are very much
threatening to go f5
h3 you can't really keep
both things under control with your
queen at the same time
and that's the problem that black is
running into so in the game
uh we saw king h7 back b3
and now finally how
to make progress with black
the answer finally arrives here
it's the move f6
and f6 is goldfin's very serious attempt
to to make uh legitimate progress
in the game uh and the reason
f6 is the attempt is because
it's cutting off this queen from
attacking
on this diagonal
this is sort of the the key idea here
he's interfering
with this queen the huge downside to
this is he's giving up control
over the seventh rank like we're saying
he's giving up this defensive potential
on the seventh rank which means that
white can now
uh try to play a bit more actively in
many cases with rookie seven
coming with shaq so f6
is the counter-intuitive idea that
gelfand came up with
to try and play for a win here you can
also
still just go h4 but this idea of f5
is going to be a little bit difficult to
face
and this is also a position you can
try to win with these two guys and
pushing them up the board slowly
but you're going to run into a lot of
the same problems that you're running
into with with pushing
the h pawn forward it's just tough to
keep both things under control
so yeah the downside is it's f6
uh ragnarok says what if queen e1 and
then g5
i'm not sure i see the point of g5 this
is
i'll take it three pawn okay
maybe means after f6 um
okay probably means after f6 i think
here
the issue with g5 is once again you're
just giving up a little bit too much
shelter now
around this king the idea like i said is
you just cut this guy off and
then it makes white's counter play
this we're coming in a little bit less
scary uh king g7
was gelfand's first move in the game uh
well what he started with in the game
after f6 then rook d2 king
f7 he wanted to control e7 directly like
this
but after queen c3 finally
he pushes through with uh with h4
finally he pushes through with h4
and now if you play the move f5 you
still go in for this
and end up in this end game that we just
looked at
but if you don't go for f5 and go for
queen c6 for example
king back to g7 f5 now
uh was actually going to be the losing
move because now there's no queen c4
i think a little bit better for white is
just
to keep the balance kind of with
something like
uh a queen back to c2 we can't really
capture this guy thanks to queen c7
check
and then this pawn is going to push up
the board but black is at least
still going to have to contend with
these two pawns at the same time sort of
like what we were talking about it's
tough for black to maintain control over
h3 and also sort of hem in this pawn on
d6
the game though f5 and the idea for
white was to go rookie 2
and challenge uh black's blockade
on the d7 square with rookie 7. and now
the this is sort of the main reason i
wanted to show this position
is because there is an insane move here
black to move
and win there is actually only one
clear win in the position for black
black to move and win what do you guys
think
black to move and win and i will give
a gold star one gold star
one pretend gold star to anyone who can
tell me
the winning move here for black
i very sincerely doubt anyone in the
chat will be able to come up with this
move
gold star it's true great wolf you could
earn yourself
a gold star if you come up with this
move that's
how much i think you're not going to
come up with it
so go on get your guesses in there get
your guesses in there
stunning moves take your guesses
we have uh what do we have here
we have king f7 suggested queen c5
suggested h3 suggested rook f7 suggested
can you trade gold stars for brownie
points no it's
only it's just a gold star king h6 queen
c5
so king h6 was played in the game and
it's true that golfing went on to win
but it's not clear it's not a clear win
unfortunately
white has chances after king h6
it's no gold star for you there's one
move that is
clearly ending the game
h3 7 25.
give me a fade okay i'll give you guys
something 25 ends the game
queen e5 ends the game just not with the
result we want
king fa to suggest that queen g4 no
nobody has it no gold stars for anybody
just come on give me legal moves
just put all the legal moves in the chat
you'll get it eventually i want to give
out a gold star
king i can't know you guys no it's too
sensible any hints
there's only so many legal moves g4 no
not g5 no no ah nobody's gonna get a
gold star a6 no
king aj no no no no but he gets it tyler
tyler gets the gold star the winning
move is a5
of course it's a5 how could you guys not
get a5
gold star to tyler to diet
he gets the gold star a5 is the winning
move
who understands the move a5 i certainly
didn't at first but
the very clear point is that black is
going to
checkmate the white king rookie 7
check would mean rick takes e7 pawn
takes c7
queen f2 check king a3 queen d4
and this is some stunning
geometry here if i've ever seen it queen
d4
and queen a1 mate is either unstoppable
or the e pawn gets caught
this is the idea of a5 queen a1
checkmate how could you guys miss it
and now of course the best that white
can do
is make a knight with check and go king
back to a2 but this is not
going to help his chances if he just
goes k2 directly
and of course we have queen d2 check
king a3
queen b4 check and we pick up this pawn
and win
easily with our uh extra material
what happens if e8 knight yeah well e8
knight just king f7
and you have the same problems here of
queen a1 mate
you can give one more check but now king
e7 only move
will win the game knight c8 king the
aids and we are catching this guy
one way or another queen c1
queen c5 check and good luck
stopping those guys with this guy
why is everyone such a passer well
everyone but tyler is a passer
tyler gets the gold star and
achieves the title of not patzer for
tonight
so a5 is the ridiculous ridiculous move
that would win the game
of course uh you can't step to the first
rank here either because then queen
one with check will pick up this pawn
and so
you know winning move a5 who would have
guessed it
king h6 is the much more human move
to try to win the game but now after
rookie 7
rick d8 the move d7 is actually quite
difficult
to uh to deal with here for black
uh just simply d7 and if you try to
naively push this guy
now the move queen c4 comes on the board
all of a sudden checkmates are being
threatened uh for
the opposite side and at the end of the
day
let's say g5 between f7 queen g6
i mean e6 starting to arrive
at perpetual territory where after ricky
ate
black really has nothing better than to
start repeating the moves
with queen c2 queen c1 uh highly
unfortunate stuff
in the game though d7 was missed queen
c1 check played instead
and now after g5 black is back to uh
back to completely winning
uh and yeah so now sorry i was reading
the chat just catching up a bit there
and now uh gelfand did go on to win this
game very convincingly with h3
king g6 and just pushing these guys up
the board
one after the other and
fun tactic here queen e6 seemingly
hanging a queen
but it doesn't matter because we get a
new one
and in fact we don't even care about
this queen either because this
is checkmate see pawn's coming in handy
once again
uh so queen e6 and gelfand
find safety with the king
up the board and goes on
to win this end game
easily easily winning
uh and we ran out a little i ran out of
time a little bit to to go over it
but basically once uh gelfand came up
with this
uh sort of idea
of advancing these pawns one at a time
and managed to get through
the immediate complications with this
d-pawn he was pretty much just in the
clear
to push these pawns and win the game as
long as he is a little bit careful which
is very difficult to do
against yon napomnishi but uh
once you get these pawns a little bit up
the board sort of becomes easier and
easier and easier
as the king is no longer sort of
uh a tool for white to use
to advance this pawn with things like
annoying checks and annoying perpetuals
it's uh going to be safer further up the
board
away from this pawn tougher to kind of
use those two things together
for white and then yeah gelfan gelfind
does go on to win
all right so i think we are just about
out of time then
for the end game class here tonight if
you want to
uh continue the fun head on over to our
twitch channel for a special
birthday edition of analyze your games
other than that if you're watching the
youtube video that's all from me tonight
thank you so much for joining
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time